foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
call me
[Music]
food
try to raise the hand that
feeds you
[Music]
try to take
[Music]
so
you stand alone sometimes
sometimes
[Music]
good
foreign
so
coming up on the next outriders
broadcast
we take a closer look at cooperative
play and how three outriders can work
together as they face
insurmountable odds on the battlefield
we'll also be delving deeper into the
unstoppable force
that is the devastator as well as
revealing the fourth and final class
so set your reminders and subscribe to
our channels to make sure that you
don't miss this one
my god's a sinner
my god
we awoke from one nightmare into another
not on our dying earth
but somewhere much worse
we came to enoch as our last chance a
chance at a new home
but what we found didn't save humanity
it consumed
[Music]
we awoke changed
the anomaly unleashed within us
burning's power impossible
power
enoch robs us of our humanity
yet gives us so much more
each step taking us further from what we
were
and closer to what we must become
the riverbed
[Music]
lovers
[Music]
[Music]
we stand on
as the last remnants of humanity destroy
themselves
the signal is still out there
and with it lies the key to our
salvation
we journey from the ruins of our old
world and into what lies beyond
the things i've seen even i do not
believe them
where i am taking these two there's no
coming back
you think you're dreaming
this is real
it's the end of the goddamn world out
there all this
the persistence this world
is crashing down
and what will be left
beyond here there's only death
i'm finding that signal
stand on
so
as we venture across enoch we discover a
violent new world
while we slept those that survived the
anomaly did what they could to carve out
a living
and something resembling society took
shape
we scavenge for weapons and armor and
trade what little resources we have in
order to give ourselves a fighting
chance of survival
we engineer vehicles from scratch and
set out towards the horizon
and as we push farther into the unknown
our powers alongside our knowledge of
how to use them
to understand
but as we start to understand our power
we discover there are others
who have paid a heavier price
um
[Music]
oh
many threats stand between us and the
source of the signal
those of us who survived exposure to the
anomaly
moved beyond our physical limits
we've become altered
as pyromancers we manipulate explosive
volcanic energy and devastating walls of
flames
as tricksters we manipulate the fabric
of time and space
to take our enemies by surprise
as devastators we shatter the earth
around us
a brute force powered by the planet
itself
and so our journey across enoch begins
to discover what lies at the heart of
the signal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we awoke from one nightmare into another
not on our dying earth
somewhere much worse but we awoke
changed the anomaly unleashed within us
burning with power impossible power
as the last remnants of humanity destroy
themselves
the key to our salvation is still out
there
the signal
i'm finding that signal
[Music]
[Music]
we journey from the ruins of our old
world and into what lies beyond
hello again my name is lucy and this is
the outriders broadcast
a monthly show in which we unearth and
dissect
everything that square enix and people
can fly sprawling
new rpg shooter has to offer
but first a quick recap of what we've
seen so far
back in episode 1 we looked at the deep
systems and quality of life design
decisions
that make the game built for the core
last month in episode 2 we looked at the
world and structure of outriders
and how your journey across enoch will
play out
today we are delving deeper still as we
look into how the outriders can pool
their powers together
to overcome the toughest threats that
enoch has to offer
in doing this we'll be looking at the
trickster pyromancer
and devastator in action seeing how the
abilities of each different class can be
deployed and combined
in co-op play but that's not
all we have also got another class to
throw into the mix
so we can finally reveal that the fourth
and final class
in the game is called the technomancer
so let's jump straight in and check out
the new class in action in our brand new
trailer
i have become terror
the unseen
a predator that obliterates without
warning
alone the hordes of enoch will fall
before me
but together this entire planet
will fear us
the anomaly alters us each in our own
ways yet we are drawn
down the same road into the dark heart
of
we will creation the source whatever it
holds
whatever it takes
all right let's talk technomancer
in outriders the altered are humans that
have been changed by the anomaly storm's
energy
giving them power over elemental and
physical forces
it's this same energy that destroys the
machines and technology
that were brought to enoch well for
every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
because when your outrider chooses the
technomancer class
you will gain powers directly linked to
technology
you'll be able to conjure up a variety
of different constructs from turrets and
mines and missile launchers
all the way to rocket launchers and
miniguns
that's some firepower as a long-range
support class the technomancer can be a
literal lifesaver for your allies in a
gunfight
possessing the best healing abilities
out of all four classes
but enough words let's switch over to
sven who has been field testing a new
recruit
with the help of robbie and yours truly
hey hello everyone this is sven with a
very special treat
it's time to feast your eyes on some
brand new co-op action
where i place kayla to show you the
final class in action
the class that you have all been waiting
for the technomancer
an advanced hard-hitting tactical
specialist
able to spawn a wide range of deadly
contraptions
we have a great fire team on the field
today with lucy taking hand of the
devastator
and robbie is in command of a pyromancer
so sit back
and enjoy a few minutes of intense co-op
gameplay
and we talk again in a bit
so
today we shall see victory
a great new altered fights on our side
together
[Music]
[ __ ] you
uh
oh
over ugh
oh
for this
wow
keep pushing secure that hilltop don't
give him time to be
oh
oh
um
oh
this isn't over
[Applause]
foreign
this isn't over
boom and there you have it the
technomancer has arrived and the fourth
class is finally revealed
for this specific loadout we showed you
three of the technomancers powers
a sticky proximity mine slash grenade
hybrid
a conjured rpg and a mighty pain
launcher which fires a widespread rocket
barrage
that reigns death on your enemies it
should already give you a good idea
about the versatility of this class
especially in combination with your
devastated pyromancer and trixacoa
partners
allowing many new and exciting
possibilities when it comes to refining
how the many different powers in your
fire team complement each other
and speaking about our friend devastator
lucy just showed a lot of cool new stuff
you can do with this class
in a few moments though she will dive
even more into the nitty gritty details
of the devastator in this month's
spotlight
stay tuned we hope you enjoyed this
exciting look into outrider's brutal and
thrilling co-op possibilities
and i also hope you are all already
building out your dream team in your
heads
and as always stay safe out there people
and i see you in the next outriders
broadcast
cheers guys so as you can see across the
four classes
upgrade paths and various gear choices
there are
countless ways in combining powers to
tackle the horrors of enoch
that being said each class is more than
capable
of taking on the world by themselves it
just means you might have to employ some
slightly different tactics
and on that note let's jump into another
spotlight
hot on the heels of the trickster and
the pyromancer today we are continuing
our class series
with an in-depth look at the devastator
if armored heavy hitting playstyles are
your kind of thing
you're gonna want to stick around take
it away
me
greetings outriders welcome back to our
spotlight series
videos that explore specific features of
the game today we are delving into the
third class
the ground shaking earthquaking
devastator
as devastators we shatter the earth
around us
a brute force powered by the planet
itself
who is this class for at first glance
you may think that devastators are your
typical
run-of-the-mill tank class but once you
get to know these not-so-friendly giants
you'll soon realize that they can match
the other classes regarding shared
damage
and devastation an important thing to
note is that the devastator can be a
real lynch pin in determining the flow
of battle
with a number of interrupt skills an
accomplished devastator can effectively
shut bosses down if you love slugging it
out with the enemy toe-to-toe
laughing at their pitiful attempts to
bring you down
well the devastator is your kind of
class
fundamentals the devastator is focused
around gravitational and earth-based
powers
and effects centered around three core
tennis
kinetic protection
and seismic its melee type is slightly
different from the other classes as it
inflicts the bleeding status effect onto
enemies hit by it
bleeding deals damage over time to
afflicted enemies
healing devastators recover health when
enemies perish around you
in close range now we know what you're
thinking
sounds similar to the trickster right
well there are actually some key
differences between these close quarters
killing machines at base level the
difference is that tricksters get
shields for each close range kill
and devastators just have more hp and
armor as standard
but they start to differentiate the more
upgrades you get
when upgraded devastators can achieve
bonuses to armor and health by choosing
specific
class 3 paths and nodes for example
stealing enemy armor for each enemy
slain
in close range an upgraded devastator
will most likely have the most armor and
health buffs out of
all of the classes these mechanics mean
that if you want to be an
unstoppable juggernaut as a devastator
you will need to keep chasing
into the heart of combat making sure
you're always in the thick of it
if you want to maintain your health
powers each class has eight powers in
total
you'll start with a single power and
unlock more as you level up
in this video we're showing you four of
the devastators abilities and will
showcase the other half
in the future power one
gravity leap upon using gravity leap
you will jump into the air and hover
there for a few seconds
activating the power once more whilst
targeting an enemy which will be
highlighted
in yellow will cause you to slam down on
them dealing area damage to
all nearby enemies this is an excellent
option for quickly launching yourself
into the thick of the fight
or maybe exiting combat to isolated far
away enemies
remember that devastators heal when
enemies close to them die
so this skill is key to ensuring you'll
always be close enough to enemies that
are about to
perish this is also an interrupt skill
that means that you can use it to
prevent bosses from channeling their own
skills just make sure that you don't
have it on cooldown
at those key moments
power 2 reflect bullets using reflect
bullets will activate a shield
directly in front of you while the
shield is up any bullets fired at you
will get caught in the shield preventing
all damage this makes it a great skill
to cover your allies while they get into
position
or during a team charge at the enemy
however it isn't just a defensive skill
when the skill duration ends
or when you activate the power again all
of the court bullets will be sent
flying back at nearby enemies this means
that you'll want to chase down the
biggest outpourings of lead
catch them and then throw them right
back in the enemy's face
power three impale this is the
outrider's team's personal favorite
devastator attack
want to know why that's why
when using impale you select an enemy to
interrupt them
this is highly effective when dealing
with bosses and their pesky skills
but is also a very useful ability for
dealing with mobs too
if the damage dealt by impale is lethal
the enemy will be speared by a stone
spike
granting your squad an armor bonus and
health regen
for nine seconds impale also has seven
potential modifiers that could be
applied to it through gear
for example the mod spike forest which
can be found on a legendary gear set
means that impale can strike one
additional targets
safety in numbers i don't think so
power four endless mass endless mass
releases a spinning obelisk which sucks
all nearby enemies towards its
gravitational center
think of it as your own personal black
hole
endless mass is a hugely versatile skill
and will likely form at least part of
your strategy
when playing with friends the ability to
draw large numbers of enemies into a
tightly packed clump
means that most other targeted skills
from both devastators
and other classes can be used for
gargantuan effects
as mentioned these are only half of the
devastators skills
subscribe to keep in the loop about the
other four
power combos as devastators feed off
close range kills
they need to lock distances between
enemies down very
quickly combining endless mass with
gravity leap will mean that a devastator
can
instantly be amongst the enemy causing
havoc
dishing out damage reflect bullets can
then be used to minimize damage against
you
whilst you're the center of attention
before you turn the tables on the enemy
eat lead baby
alter your devastator each class has a
tree of class point nodes that you can
activate to alter the way your builds
and skills work
class points are required by leveling up
you won't be able to fill out the class
tree but you will be able to re-spec
your
nodes to switch up your gameplay as you
go
the three branches for the devastator
are vanquisher
warden and seismic shifter
with each branch providing both major
and minor passives that affect your
character's type of damage focus
and survivability the vanquisher branch
is all about
grappling up close and personal with the
enemy and thus provides bonuses for
weapons like
shotguns or assault rifles the warden
branch will truly
move mountains and is the ultimate tank
with very high bonuses to health
armor and resistances
the seismic shifter branch is most
useful at mid-range combat
and focuses on anomaly damage for
seismic skills such as impale
this branch also combines very well with
the bleeding status effect that
devastators can
inflict damage over time fans you're
gonna love this one
additionally the equipment you use may
impact the way your skills work
too the equipment passives might reduce
the cooldown
or duration of the skill or they might
alter it on a more fundamental
level but we don't want to spoil the fun
too much today
so we will showcase these in another
video
so that's our devastator introduced no
need to shake hands
i mean they'd probably crush your palm
into dust if you did
keep an eye out on our youtube channel
for future gameplay videos and other
spotlights coming soon
you know what to do subscribe to the
notification bell follow us on social
media
all that good stuff we hope the
devastator class
rocked your wills and we'll see you next
time
sadly that is pretty much everything we
have for you for broadcast three
a new class to whet your appetites look
at how beautifully brutal co-op can be
and everything you need to get started
as the devastator
am i missing anything
i am going to pass over to robbie who
has been going through your questions
and your comments from the last
broadcast where you at robbie
thanks lucy if you would like your
question answered on the broadcast
be sure to follow us on your favorite
social network
and use the hashtag outriders
let's jump into your questions this
month what platforms and stores
is outriders coming to we want as many
players as possible to experience the
journey across enoch
so on pc outriders will be available on
both steam and epic game store and we
will also be releasing on xbox one
xbox series x playstation 4 and
playstation 5. we'll also be releasing
on stadia
in 2021 how does outrider's story
progress and will i be able to play from
start to finish with friends
outriders has a drop-in dropout style of
co-op play
once players have finished the beginning
prologue you and your friends will be
able to complete our riders together or
tackle the game with completely
different people at different sections
or you can solo the entire game by
yourself
the choice is completely yours if you
jump into a lobby in which a player is
further ahead than you in the story
the game will warn you before you fully
join to avoid spoilers
are we seeing a lower level cap where
grinding for gear is essential
so players will be able to grind for
gear yes but finding the best build
is dependent on a lot more than just
coming across a legendary through pure
luck
how you spec your character using the
skill tree and how you modify
your existing gear with different gear
mods you might like over time
will play a big role in your combat
effectiveness and survivability
and of course there is the question of
skill because no matter how amazing your
gear
you won't survive long at the top tiers
of outriders if you don't learn how to
master your equipment
what's the fourth class we're really
excited to reveal in broadcast three the
fourth
and final class the technomancer a
flexible class with both support and
destructive potential
that has a variety of amazing anomaly
powered weaponry at their disposal
the technomaster class is also the only
class that in addition to their own
sustained mechanics can heal other
players with their powers
tune into our next broadcast for a
spotlight on the technomancer and its
skills
and mechanics thanks to everyone that
sent in their questions for broadcast
three
next time we will be back to answer more
of your gameplay based questions so just
keep sending them in for the chance to
have them answered next time on the
outriders broadcast
thank you robbie as always keep an eye
on our social channels
for the question call out for broadcast
4. you never know
your question could be answered by
robbie next month okay that really is
everything now
thank you so much for watching we really
hope you enjoyed it
learnt something new and most
importantly our super soaked forward the
technomancer
we'll see you next time next time
on the outriders broadcast we're taking
a look at
endgame and what awaits you after your
search for the signal
comes to an end where do you go what
do you do and most importantly how do
you go about perfecting your personal
outrider build as well as this we'll be
checking out the technomancer
in our final class spotlights see you
then
so
you